>>Allyson: The level of student
engagement here is incredible,
and it's just the feeling you get
when you walk in the building.
>>We're a career and
technical high school.
The students come here because
they have an interest in something
and they're able to make
connections with their technical path,
and then they learn how to apply
it through the math, the sciences
and the English, so that you have
this really well rounded, interested,
high level student who's doing
something that they love.
>>Gregory: I teach my architecture
classes in a way where students get
to apply the relationships to academics.
They also get to understand a bit
about art, a bit about design,
a little bit about everything really.
>>One thing I'd like to do
first is to sort of recap
so that we can knock these
site-specific aspects of the project.
>>For the past six years,
we've been going
to the Pocono Environmental
Education Center.
I team up with a history
teacher and a science teacher
for that large scale project.
>>Jamie: It is a national
park in Poconos, Pennsylvania.
>>Gregory: I decided to have students
demonstrate their understanding
of architecture by designing a
pavilion that would be site-specific
to the Pocono Environment
Education Center.
>>Cathy: My class is involved
in the project, just by looking
at national parks and conservation of
different habitats, different species.
>>Jamie: I'm touching on the
history of national parks
and how they were founded, and
how without Teddy Roosevelt,
there would be no national parks.
>>What I want you to do, start
researching different national parks
and see if there are
historical monuments within them.
And I want you to talk about the
different features and how does
that change the features of the park?
>>Gregory: Prior to going on the trip,
we'll hold a seminar with students
to give them some connections to
that trip, so that we can bring
that experience back to the classroom.
>>Cathy: Having input from the different
subjects areas provides something
that maybe wasn't thought of originally.
>>Gregory: Today, Miss Velasquez
and Miss Yuhas are also here
to give their perspective on things.
>>Jamie: This and this remind me
of Epcot Center, that big dome.
This design and that shape.
>>Some students want to focus
on structures and monuments
that they've seen in the past.
Some students just want feedback,
so they have three different
teachers that they can speak to.
>>Cathy: Some of the students
were working on a lot of designs
and incorporated a lot
of biology concepts.
>>Enzo: So first I was
working with a dandelion,
so then I was like, can
you kind of see it?
It's like a sphere, but then I was like,
oh, this looks better flipped over.
So I wanted to make the water
filter down with these pipes.
>>Gregory: Collaborative projects are
really used to bring everything together
to show relevancy and
to break down the silos
between the different courses of study.
>>Allyson: If I have a cohort
of teachers working together,
I give them common planning time,
so that they can specifically
plan based around the vocation.
So the technical instructor will
say, "This is what I'm doing.
How can you contribute to this project?"
We don't force it, we
find ways to support it.
>>Jamie: Someone will say what
they're doing in their class
and it will spark a conversation
and then someone will say, "Oh,
I'm doing this in my class."
And if something can
tie in, let's do it.
>>Cathy: It's good for them
to get a different perspective
on topics from the different areas.
>>Jamie: Students come to the
class with more knowledge.
They're getting different mindsets,
different viewpoints
and different material.
>>Allyson: We're trying to show
them how they need to be able
to think critically, think creatively
and independently, while
working in the team.